u.s intelligence report released today
states that saudi arabia's crown prince
was aware of and likely approved the
killing
of u.s based journalist jamal khashoggi
the washington post writer was murdered
inside the saudi consulate in istanbul
in 2018
saudi arabia says the report has
unjustified and
inaccurate conclusions khashoggi was a
critic of crown prince
mohammed bin salman's authoritarian
consolidation of power
let's talk about the khashoggi report
the us airstrikes in syria and the next
steps with iran and this administration
with norman rule he is a former national
intelligence manager for iran
and a former senior cia middle east
expert
norm thanks for being here my pleasure
let's start with the strikes and the
administration
saying it's essentially a warning shot
your thoughts on the strategic
uh importance of it or the criticism
they're taking
for it where what about this strike
so let me explain what's happened here
in this case the united states has
either been attacked or received
information of an attack and has
responded with
public and private warnings to iran not
to undertake those attack
iran failed to do so and we then
responded with an
action that demonstrates that we're not
going to allow iran to destabilize iraq
but we're demonstrating our power and
our intelligence and our capacity to
strike those who are behind the attack
here's the question will iran respond by
getting the message
or just taking it up another step on the
escalatory ladder
to test our will in the long run
yeah meantime as this is happening as i
just mentioned with trey the
administration is clearly making moves
to get back into some sort of
nuclear deal uh there were reports that
some
members of the administration were kind
of talking to the iranians
including secretary kerry as the trump
administration was in office
thoughts about that and what it means
for the strategic middle east
geopolitically
well first diplomacy is always a good
thing this said
engagement thus far with iran has not
been producing i believe what the
administration seeks
in addition to arriving with the with
the idea that they would engage with
iran in return to the nuclear deal if
possible
the administration has also been
sympathetic to iranian requests for
funding through the imf
look what we've seen in response attacks
on u.s troops in iraq
an attack today on an israeli vessel in
the gulf of oman that looks like the
irgc
iran is refusing to cooperate with the
iaea
thus far iran is testing our fortitude
and seeing how far it can push
the biden administration and the
international community for additional
concessions
all right i want to read from this
intelligence report about saudi
uh the assessing the saudi government's
role in the killing of jamal khashoggi
saudi arabia's crown prince mohammed bin
salman approved an operation in istanbul
turkey to capture or kill
saudi journalist jamal khashoggi the
crown prince viewed khashoggi as a
threat to the kingdom
and broadly supported using violent
measures if necessary to silence him
you know i asked the foreign minister
about this back in october
of 2018 here's an exchange i had
you're an authoritarian government
you're saying that the crown prince
mohammed bin salman
did not know about this at all even
though there are
members of this 15-person team that are
closely aligned with him
well brett first of all we're not an
authoritarian government we're a
monarchy
we have our checks and balances we have
our systems the individuals
who did this did this outside the scope
of their authority this is an abrasion
this is a mistake this is a criminal act
and those responsible
for it will be punished to the original
question did the crown prince know
anything about it
if there were people closely tied to him
involved in this operation
there weren't people closely tied to him
who were involved in this operation
there were pictures of some security
officers
who may have been part of his security
detail from time to time
but this is normal this was an operation
that was a rogue operation
so this administration choosing to
declassify this report
not seeing any strict uh punishments for
mbs the crown prince your thoughts on
this and the fallout in the middle east
well the administration has achieved
today several things
first this is another uh step in its
evolution of resetting relations with
saudi arabia
in recent weeks we've seen the president
denied the opportunity to speak with
uh the crown prince himself they've
ended an arms deal
uh they've also cut back on support of
with saudi arabia
regarding yemen but this report makes it
very clear the u.s intelligence
community believes or assesses that the
crown prince played or played a
decision-making role in this action
i should note this report provides no
evidence it appears to be based on
the intelligence community's
understanding of how saudi arabia works
less than the actual information i
should also note that despite this
report there have been routine
discussions between the united states
leadership in saudi arabia
on multiple security issues within the
last few weeks the secretary of state
the secretary of defense
the president himself have all engaged
their counterparts and the very
influential saudi ambassador to the
united states has been in routine
contact i understand
with the state department and the
national security council so the reset
continues
but the broader relations between the
united states and riyadh
on issues of importance to each of our
countries does go on
and just quickly obviously the last
administration used the gulf states to
kind of do a different way to middle
east peace and what
we're having some success obviously
significant success
does this change that is this
administration taking
an opposite view with not only iran but
the gulf states
not regarding the gulf states and israel
this administration will attempt to
further the success of the trump
administration which was
significant and historic but i think
that success will take some time to
develop
i also believe the administration will
push the gulf states to
somehow engage iran and they're going to
be reluctant to do so since they're
under a routine attack
by iran's goods force norman rule we
really appreciate your perspective
always thank you very much
my pleasure